indeed one D4 to which yawn responds by
developing his Knight
all right next question what is Young
going to plan move to
it must be E6
must be six
yeah
in the past exactly but in the world
championship match and in the candidates
he's stuck to E6
great call and ding no nimzo for us
today he develops the Knight to F3 It's
gotta be the castle Yeah
and indeed whoa what
he Mouse no he must live the G Pawn is
the one it's the other one it's not that
one
it happens you know three
the board H3 right it happens I mean he
tried to play G3 the the hand slipped to
the right and
this is crazy this is crazy wow
h2h3 has just been played on move four
of this Queen's Gambit decline position
not G3 folks that's the Catalan H3
preparing chief